ya hemos visto que si iniciamos con la
ecuación diferencial derivada de ye
respecto de x igual ayer y con una
condición inicial de digamos ya evaluada
en 0 igual a 1
entonces obtenemos la solución está
solución particular verdad para esta
condición inicial de evaluada en x igual
a ea la x y si no te gusta la anotación
de función simplemente puedes ponerlo
como de iguala
a la equis verdad y todo esto es muy
fácil de hacer porque es una ecuación
diferencial de variables separables pero
como verás a medida que avances en este
mundo de las ecuaciones diferenciales la
mayoría de las ecuaciones diferenciales
no son tan fáciles de resolver y de
hecho muchas de ellas son imposibles de
resolver usando métodos analíticos así
que con esto dicho pues que vamos a
hacer muchos fenómenos naturales se
describen muy bien con las ecuaciones
diferenciales pero si no podemos
resolverlas entonces deberíamos
rendirnos
la respuesta es no no te rindas porque
ahora tenemos algo muy importante casi
todos en nuestras manos que son las
computadoras y son muy buenas con los
métodos numéricos para aproximar
soluciones de ecuaciones diferenciales y
al menos ver cómo son ahora bien en este
vídeo vamos a explorar uno de los
métodos numéricos más directos para
proxy para aproximar una solución
particular así que para eso vamos a
empezar dibujando una tabla que íbamos a
dibujar una tabla aquí vamos a poner x
vamos a poner allí verdad ahí tenemos
algo así y vamos a pintar tanto más bien
vamos a poner los valores también de la
derivada de ye con respecto de x verdad
y si se acuerdan cuando hicimos campos
dependientes lo que hacíamos con esta
tabla era por ejemplo si x le dábamos un
valor cero
aquí en particular pues sabemos que la
derivada de perdón el valor de g
1 verdad el valor de g es uno verdad en
nuestra condición inicial y la pendiente
nos dice que es el valor de ya que en
este caso sería 1 verdad y entonces uno
podría ir haciendo este este método con
todos estos puntos del plano con un
montón de puntos del plano y entonces al
menos podemos esbozar cómo es la
pendiente de las soluciones en cada
punto verdad entonces algo similar vamos
a hacer con esta condición inicial y
para para ir creando este método así que
déjenme hacerlo con un color que llame
más la atención verdad entonces aquí
estamos diciendo que en la condición
inicial es decir en x igual a cero
igual a 1 que es este punto de aquí la
pendiente vale 1
ok más o menos esa es la pendiente y a
diferencia de lo que hemos estado
manejando con los campos dependientes en
vez de hacerlo con muchos puntos vamos a
suponer que está pendiente es es la
misma o es constante hasta el siguiente
valor de equis que queramos elegir y
usamos
vamos a usar esa idea para hallar el
siguiente valor de ye que corresponde a
esta solución particular verdad entonces
qué es lo que quiero decir con todo esto
si nosotros consideramos digamos un
cambio en x una delta x igual a 1 es
decir vamos a ir aumentando x de uno en
uno entonces podemos tomarnos por
ejemplo podemos sumar uno verdad que es
nuestro delta xy ver qué pasa con la
solución que pasa en x igual a 1 verdad
y si consideramos que está pendiente es
constante verdad entonces al aumentar
uno en x debe aumentar uno de verdad
entonces el siguiente punto que lo voy a
poner de verde sería este de aquí muy
bien si si nosotros extendemos está
pendiente de verdad si nosotros
hiciéramos está pendiente igual a 1 ahí
lo tienen entonces este sería nuestro
siguiente punto verdad que de hecho de
hecho lo pinté mal debería estar
arriba ahí está verdad en 1 2
ahí está verdad avance 1 en x entonces
avanzó 1 y entonces la aie tendría que
ser 2 verdad ahora bien si nos fijamos
si pensamos que este es un punto de la
solución cuál sería su pendiente pues la
pendiente tendría que ser 2 verdad nos
dice que es el valor de y entonces a
partir de este punto por ejemplo ahora
si tomamos un color rosa nos dice que si
avanzamos 1 en x tenemos que avanzar 2
en de verdad entonces si avanzamos 1 en
x que sería poner aquí 2 tenemos que
avanzar 12 y eso sí significa que
estaríamos en el valor 4 verdad entonces
y tendríamos que estar en el valor 4 ahí
lo tienen y esto sería suponer que la
pendiente es constante y vale 2 verdad
ahora bien eso es aquí en este punto
cuál sería la pendiente ahora ya que
estamos en este nuevo punto en el 24
pues la pendiente tendría que hacer 4
verdad así que vamos a hacer un último
punto es decir vamos a sumarle 1 a las x
tendremos aquí 3 y si la pendiente vale
4 esto significa que al aumentar 1 en x
aumentamos 4 en que es decir tendría que
estar en el 8 verdad entonces aquí está
el 8 y acá arriba está el 3 perdón aquí
a la derecha está el 3 y más o menos
entonces se ve algo así verdad más o
menos ahí tenemos una aproximación de lo
que es la solución y entonces tú dirás
bueno esto realmente es una muy mala
aproximación verdad si nos fijamos en el
error cómo es que va
pues dirás que esta es una muy mala
aproximación y yo te diría que en
realidad depende de cuáles sean tus
objetivos verdad yo aquí quise hacer
este ejemplo porque quería hacerlo a
mano verdad y por eso tomé mismo digamos
mis brincos que hago en x o las
distancias que tengo entre cada valor de
x muy grande verdad vale 1 así que
nosotros podríamos intentar hacer otra
aproximación tomando por ejemplo un
delta x igual a algo más pequeño por
ejemplo delta x igual a un medio que es
0.5 verdad entonces podríamos intentar
hacerlo con ese valor vamos a ver que
nos da vamos a tomarnos una nueva tabla
vamos a poner aquí x
x vamos a poner la aie y vamos a poner
el valor de la derivada de jake con
respecto de x ahora nosotros tenemos que
partir nuevamente de la condición
inicial que es el 01 verdad y la
pendiente vale 1 y entonces seguimos
estando en esta condición inicial muy
bien ahora bien si nosotros aumentamos
punto 5 ahora nos movemos y sumamos 0.5
ahora estamos en el 0.5 y si aumentamos
fíjense muy bien si por cada uno que
aumentamos de x aumentamos 1 dl si
aumentamos punto 5 vamos a tener que
aumentar 0.5 y eso nos dice que hay que
estar en 1.5 verdad entonces si se dan
cuenta
ya tenemos una mejor aproximación de lo
que es la solución yo sé que aquí se va
a ver muy amontonado pero vamos a ir
viendo que esto va a verse cada vez
mejor verdad
y ahora estamos en este punto en el 0.5
verdad y 1.5 la derivada en ese punto es
el valor de g justamente que es 1.5 es
decir la pendiente de la solución en ese
en ese punto en particular verdad
entonces si nosotros volvemos a agregar
0.5 digamos no se ha dado con un color
morado
en un color morado y agregamos 0.5
entonces ahora ya nos encontramos en el
punto 1 verdad y si por cada uno de x
que avancemos aumentamos 1.5 d y
entonces si aumentamos la mitad de x
bueno la más bien un medio perdón
entonces vamos a tener que aumentar 0.75
que al sumarse lo a esta coordenada que
ya teníamos será 2.25 verdad entonces
aquí estaremos en 2.25 que es un punto
que más o menos corresponde a esa altura
y si te das cuenta nada más de estos
tres puntos se va viendo que tenemos una
mejor aproximación de nuestra solución
recordemos que la solución es de x igual
a la x entonces si queremos fijarnos por
ejemplo en el punto 1 lleno 1 la
solución debería ser es verdad que de
hecho sabemos que es el número de oil
ergo verdad
y si nos fijamos en esta aproximación
tenemos que es 2.25 verdad
perdón en x igual a 1 mientras que en
esta en este otro ejemplo teníamos que
validar 2 verdad entonces si te das
cuenta esta es una muy mala aproximación
esto es un poco mejor porque el valor de
es más o menos 2.70 y algo de hecho si
tomáramos una delta x por ejemplo de 0.0
0001 entonces tendríamos una mucha o una
mejor aproximación de la solución y de
hecho podríamos calcular con mayor
precisión el valor de esta constante
verdad entonces como podrás haberte dado
cuenta en este vídeo muchas ecuaciones
diferenciales se pueden simular usando
distintos métodos numéricos y este es el
más directo de ellos y bueno te
preguntarás cómo se llama este método en
particular pues este método se le conoce
como el método de hoy leer justamente
hoy leer del que hablábamos hace unos
segundos verdad hoy leer el matemático
famoso
que de hecho trabajó en muchísimas áreas
pero bueno este método se le conoce
justamente como el método de hoy leer
entonces si te das cuenta este método
ayuda muchísimo a calcular el valor de
con una mayor precisión aunque en
realidad nos ayuda también a encontrar
soluciones de ecuaciones diferenciales
al menos de una forma aproximada